hey this is Pete peppers from candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
level 105 candy crush soda saga walked
through with some commentary making this
video to highlight the tips from the god
I wrote a while ago he updated the
layout recently they took out the honey
on the outside it makes it a little bit
easier but it's still really tough so
people still have trouble and we had
some requests with for this in our group
so weird I just figured I'd make a new
one and talk about the decision so in
the beginning there's really not much to
talk about we're just trying to work our
way down so we can get down to the
coloring candy the trapped in the bottom
like we talked about in the guide and
can't usually move in a straight line
it's a small board and all the colors
aren't in play you can tell by seeing
the dark blue so you have seven colors
in a lot of big space so it's hard to
set up matches and get real tricky so or
technical I should say so in the
beginning you can see I'm just you going
with what I have and I'm trying to open
up the sides you know clear out the
honey when I don't have good matches
going down because that will give me
more opportunities so now I got a couple
matches here where I can work my way
down
things you know you want to make
specials when you can and they might
have to sit there for a while until you
can walk some other pieces down here's a
good spot where we can um we can bring
that green piece down hopefully yeah for
the purple and we can make a yeah a rat
candy over here
and if we can get that wrapped candy
above the honey on the collar a candy
right now will be ill open it up because
it'll hit it twice so like here we can
move it out a little bit and open up the
side so we do that and then like that
would have been cool if you wasn't able
to do that okay it didn't work it got
cleared so that's fine now I kind of
want to set off this green one so I can
drop these greens together to make a
green that's three on the left and that
old that'll expose the the coloring
candy for us
excuse me yeah so we'll just go ahead
and do that and now we don't use the
common Kenny until we can match it with
like up here we can make a green striped
and then we could try to walk that down
and match that with the coloring candy
because you know there's a lot of honey
and ice on this level and um we're just
we're just not gonna get through it off
we don't make this
that's the tution two specials together
all right see how the walking it downs
working fine we can bless the yellow and
then the blue will be set up right on
the left the light blue and sometimes
like right before I set this off I'll
look to see if there's anything that I
can do to clear out like that match on
the side just clears out a little bit
more that's a little bit more important
to do if you're gonna match it with a
fish but um because like there you can
kind of see I wasted a move because that
that row got cleared out like multiple
times and that's a pretty good that's
pretty good that you see how effective
that is we got that one we can pop
straight out and then this one over here
we can pop out we can make this fish
first and like come in handy later and
then the perfect well the the purple
mascot moves but um
that's all right we have so you have a
blue [ __ ] the two blue fish
let's go ahead and get rid of the dark
blue one battlebot then I'll set up the
green match there so now we have two
pieces ice and we have this green match
and the blue fish so all we have to do
is take these out oh that was a big
mistake oh I should have monster green
first let that be a lesson that you
don't have to learn for yourself but on
myself I've matches here so you're gonna
have to probably set something love this
is where I really miss pepper panic saga
because you know you'd be able make some
cool matches and some some shock waves
around I have to get a little more
technical here the purple stripe there I
didn't bother to make that because um
that would just be a waste of a move and
we have to make every one count and now
I kind of see how we can set it up we
can um we can make this stripe came here
and then make the orange match at the
bottom and that'll set up the cross shot
on the very last move so a little bit of
thinking and then you can you can do it
when you only have one nose don't do
what I do and just take the easy one and
then use the fish afterwards but that's
how it works the tips and the guide will
help if you're not exactly sure what
you're trying to do and like the video
if you found that helpful visit our site
candy crush soda saga tips calm to find
out everything you need to know about
the game and we'll see you real soon
thanks